j'ai une bonne nouvelle je crois qu'on a
retrouvé tiphaine ça rassure bérenger
sam assure hervé ça rassure marie aussi
parce qu'on avait du gâteau au chocolat
peut-être pour vous si vous êtes sages
visiblement on arrose coacher les lignes
on en était toute à l'heure typhaine à
se dire que pour séduire les lecteurs
que nous sommes et bien il y avait des
choses sympathiques pour nos ados et je
pense que les parents peuvent traquer
avec un roman qui devient fantastique
c'est ça oui oui alors j'espère que vous
m'entendez en effet je crois que j'étais
perdue dans la forêt comme ce premier
roman qui s'appelle la gueule du loup
c'est un roman d'eric pessan publié à
l'école des loisirs et justement la
gueule du loup c'est un lieu-dit perdu
dans la forêt où se réfugient une
adolescente de 16 ans nommé joe son
petit frère et sa mère au moment où le
confinement s'apprête à être déclaré
alors il pense profiter du grand air et
passer un bon moment plutôt que d'être
enfermés dans un appartement mais ça va
pas du tout se passait comme ça déjà
parce qu'il n'y a pas de réseau et donc
c'est difficile de communiquer et de
faire ses devoirs l'école à distance et
puis parce qu'il ya des phénomènes
étranges qui commence à se produire avec
des bruits voilà des des phénomènes
vraiment étrange je veux pas trop vous
en dire et on retrouve la figure du loup
vous savez comme dans les contes qui
symbolise toutes les menaces alors le
mal être adolescent
les comment dire la maladie l' isolement
les secrets de famille je vous en dis
pas plus mais ça c'est un thriller c'est
aussi un roman fantastique on ne lâche
pas jusqu'à la dernière page et c'est à
la dernière page qu'on sait enfin ce qui
se passe dans cette maison dans cette
gueule du loup vraiment je vous le
conseille c'est à partir de 12 ans ça
fait un point commun avec hervé renoh
notre meilleur ouvrier de france
designer maquettiste qui est sur ce
plateau qui sait on l'a vu tout à
l'heure à des maquettes fantastique à
refléter les châteaux incroyable oui
château et puis oui surtout pour les
décors de vitrines où l'âge on me laisse
le loisir de m'évader très loin cette
fois ci ils sont en plastique parce que
parfois on pose des bougies au dessus
oui entre amis et puis là par contre il
faut lutter contre les éclairages qui
représente de la chaleur et puis le
soleil donc il faut il faut quelque
chose qui tienne qui tiennent ce qu'il
soit costaud pour la longévité mais
c'est vrai que là je suis parti avec le
louvre âge là bas c'est bien ça
s'appelle la gueule du loup d'eric
pessan bien là notre romain de proposer
un roman d'apprentissage à nous proposer
sur un ado dont la maman est disparu
brutalement et qui n'arrivent pas
forcément à tourner la page c'est pas
facile oui alors dit comme ça ça
pourrait faire peur vous dit non je vais
pas offrir ça mon ado mais je voulais
dit ses romans la utilise le fantastique
pour qu'on ne lâche pas le livre
s'appelle les mots fantôme c'est un
livre de david moyes et essai publié
chez didier jeunesse alors elliott part
au square avec sa jeune soeur et laisse
sa mère en train de préparer des cookies
et quand il revient elle est morte et on
lui dit écoutez circulez ya rien à voir
c'est un suicide mais lui il n'y croit
pas et quand il rencontre une jeune
fille lila qui a des hallucinations et
qui lui dit j'ai vu ta mère eh bien il
se lance dans une enquête peuplé de
fantômes de révélations c'est vraiment
passionnant ont trait de plein plein de
sujets alors les maladies psychiques les
secrets de famille aussi et c'est
passionnant c'est tout un univers à
découvrir je vous le conseille alors là
c'est plutôt à partir de 13 ans mais
vous n'allez pas lâcher ce roman et
comme je vous le disais hé bien on
utilise les fantômes les contres les
comptes les figures un peu fantastique
pour que ce soit pas trop douloureux
pour d'univers le vôtre bérenger papa
sadar on va le découvrir dans quelques
minutes mais là je croise le regard d'un
mignon depuis tout à l'heure et que je
trouve formidable petit mignon la quête
en faire c'est ça endemol est en métal
génial c'est génial on a terminé en
beauté
dites-moi tiphaine c'est pas un livre
mais de deux dont vous voudriez nous
parler en une minute c'est possible
j'espère je vais essayer en tout cas
c'est la trappe malheur de fabrice
hadjadj c'est publié à la joie de lire
et là c'est tout un univers qui va
s'ouvrir devant vous grâce aux héros
alors il s'appelle jacob drôme c'est un
fils de meunier plus ou moins classique
mais il a un don il n'est pas blessé en
fait dès qu'il a une blessure elle
cicatrices d'automatiquement et dont il
ne peut pas mourir mais c'est ça
s'accompagne d'une malédiction c'est à
dire si quelqu'un de killem est blessé
et bien c'est lui qui prend cette
blessure sur lui alors ses parents
décident qu'il ne devra plus aimés et
essaye de lui façonner un coeur de
pierre alors ça finit évidemment en
odyssée puisque eh bien ils fuient
perpétuellement il ne doit pas aimer il
ne peut pas mourir imaginé cette
malédiction c'est un univers
complètement fantasmagorique on croise
des espèces d'être au grand coeur des
monstres on passe par un cirque enfin je
vous le conseille ça plaira aux ados
c'est un peu freak c'est un peu geek
vous allez à adorer si vous avez on va
dire 14 ans est un conte philosophique
je vous le conseil a déjà deux tomes
voilà à mettre dans toutes les
bibliothèques bien sûr j'adore merci
tiphaine pfeiffer je pense que vous
allez beaucoup aimé aussi ce que nous
propose bérenger se précise que votre
sélection livre on la retrouve
évidemment sur les réseaux sociaux qui
vont revenir régulièrement pour plein
d'autres livres qu'il ya dans notre
bibliothèque on envoie quelques uns
juste derrière